[Music]
hello and welcome to episode 207 of the
weekly Google cloud platform podcast I'm
mark and I'm here with my colleague also
mark yep I'm back again for just a
little bit for just a yearly recap which
is also super exciting because it's a
yearly recap of all the cool things that
have happened in 2019 I'm basically
doing a John Farnham farewell tour which
is a joke only Australians are gonna get
because no one else knows who John
Farnham is so true so true haha I'll
pretend to understand that Google it's
fine I will Google it after the podcast
but super excited to be chatting with
mark for at least one more reoccurring
random guest appearance there we go as
we as we do talk about all the cool
things that have happened over 2019 yeah
it's been a good year it's not been
terrible I can't complain too much - the
part where you step down as a full time
host mark which of course is devastating
to all of us but also exciting because
of all the new people who are on it now
and all the new voices and that makes me
very happy
absolutely and plus we always have Robo
bando
if we need him glad to be of service
mate so going on with that it has been a
really cool year and I think we'd like
to talk about the top 10 episodes of
this year but before we dive into that I
think we should talk about our favorite
episodes as well yeah now we absolutely
should talk about our favorite episodes
we didn't you there first
absolutely so my favorite episode was
definitely chatting data science with
Chris Alban and myself and Michelle
hosted that one and that's episode 193
if people are looking for it what was
that about
yeah so that episode was super exciting
because we got a chance to talk with
Chris about all the cool things he's
doing at devoted health but it was also
a lot about just data science in general
you know he was talking about his
machine learning flashcards which I
think really brought a lot of complex
terminology a lot of complex different
constructions that are connected to
machine learning and said here's how you
can kind of understand them access them
and really get them in a way that really
lowered the barrier to entry and I think
he was talking a lot about the human
side of data science and where the
actual application was far more
important than running all these large
studies machine learning and data
science in general are all becoming a
little bit easier to do so he was much
more interested in like well what do you
do
with them where's the impact of those
and so that conversation with Chris was
really fascinating because he drove into
why that's so important and that's why
you know devoted health but really all
the things that Chris talks about really
Drive more into impact than anything
else very very cool
what about your favorite episode I got a
couple of favorites it's actually
interesting like noting that neither of
our episodes are in the top 10 downloads
but that's kind of because we have
diverse backgrounds of interests
absolutely I particularly like doing
blockchain with Alan day and I want to
say that not ironically I think in the
tech industry we maybe make fun of this
maybe a little bit more than we should I
don't know
definitely goes up a lot and random
jokes and whatnot but I was always some
I don't know really anything about
blockchain or Bitcoin mining or anything
along those kind of lines so to sit down
with Alan and be like okay what is this
thing - what is it actually useful for
what can you do on GCP with it it was
really good from a very practical point
of view and just kind of be like okay
like let's kind of go through the hype
get through that and then be like okay
like what's the reality here what is
that actually useful for and that was
never super interesting and some of the
stuff we have going on with like
bigquery and some cryptocurrency type
stuff was super interesting - I was also
really good fun because it was the first
time I got to be on the podcast with
kata Morgan and I really liked that so
that might be very happy yeah it was an
awesome episode and honestly anything
that brings a little bit more realistic
understanding of what blockchain is yeah
I think we just need more of that so
introducing the Google Cloud blockchain
podcast where everything is blockchain
every episode awesome I'll call rebel
Wilson and maybe we can host it together
let's not go that far okay no no
blockchain podcast yeah there you go I
do any other favorite episodes the Chris
Albert episode was a really great one
for data science we actually got to talk
to another fellow John from primer AI
you know again this was a host that
Michelle had worked very hard to bring
in yeah and we got to hear some really
interesting stories I think John shared
just a fascinating life story of how he
got to data science and where he is and
all the cool things that he does now a
vehicle I thought that was a really good
listen but it was really just
fascinating to hear about the 18
different paths he took and that story
mentioned a lot about working with the
government and working with some very
interesting companies in China and
testing fish for pregnancy I mean it
went all over the place it's always
super interesting I find listening to
some stories that people take especially
with non-traditional backgrounds about
how they get into
can the Career Development they've had
how they ended up where they ended up
because if you like they check like
there's no one true path and it's always
very interesting to see how people ended
up here yeah you said there's such a
diverse background and most of the times
these people aren't starting in tech
they're starting with much more you know
kind of focused areas of what they
wanted to go into and then just ended up
in tech because they have that
background expertise yeah absolutely so
one of my other favorite ones that I
wanna bring up which is episode 196
which is the episode with Phoenix labs
if anyone played dauntless I mean I have
to mention something to do with games I
think it's just a given well I really
like this episode not only because you
know cool game and stuff line breaking
oh kubernetes excetera thing i like
about this is it's we've definitely done
stories talking about like the PSO team
and like some of the sales support teams
and like how we do things from the
Google side to support customers but it
was really great to hear from the
customer side of like what was it like
as an experience to launch a large-scale
game that was like through the roof in
terms of like beyond the expectations of
what they were gonna get traffic-wise
and player wise and then see what their
perspective was on the support they were
getting from the Google cloud team and
how they were supported at launch
unsurprisingly giving us the podcast it
was relatively positive but it was it
was really interesting just to see their
perspective and sort of give some ideas
for other people who are looking at
maybe you want some large-scale things
how Google can help yeah I thought we
got a good perspective of that on the
super solid episode as well oh nice yeah
where they talked a lot about you know
using a gonna suck orce and kind of
their process there before it was 1.0
and kind of the experience they had
working with Google and you know
obviously they also had a great
experience with it but it was very cool
that for them to talk about like these
two engineers who didn't have any
kubernetes experience yep going into
launching full-scale back-end for gaming
yeah
and how they did that that was super
super cool so definitely know their
episode worth checking out
cool so the reality is is every episode
as our favorite I think is what this
comes down to
well the episodes in on our favorites
we're not gonna mention I make anyone
upset donkey I'm kidding they're all
they're all fantastic they're all
fantastic episodes but it would be worth
to mention that we do have the top 10
episodes as rated by the viewer I guess
by the episode views so we'll call that
rated by the viewers that works so I'm
in a lot of there's a lot who you know
what that means people really like
hearing you talk though you're in the
top I am in the
one which makes me feel so good inside
but I know it wasn't because of me it
was because was because of that it was
because because of Gabi a hundred
percent we'll talk about that when we go
there but shall we start from the bottom
up there okay let's do that all right
well then let's start with guess a
drumroll would be appropriate here
episode number 10 which we have as cloud
sequel yep this one was mark and Gabi as
well you know Gabi talks a lot about
cloud sequel and other database solution
offerings as well but you know what were
you kind of your takeaways from that
episode I actually really liked this
episode
it actually Hawkins me back to it a
number of years ago where we did like an
episode on like just straight GCE VMs
which was also hugely popular cloud
sequel it's just a staple of things that
people need you know we work in devrel
and sometimes it's very nice to show up
and do all the shiny stuff and just be
like oh my god look at this cool new
thing that like screws up and uses
amazing stuff sometimes you just need to
stick stuff in the database so it's
always great to just have this sort of
workhorse type technology to talk about
it and just get it done yeah I know my
sequel Postgres aren't going anywhere
anytime soon and it's definitely a need
for a lot of people so it sounds like
that'd be a cool episode to check out if
you want a refresher on what's new with
cloud sequel and I'm sure there's plenty
more coming up absolutely set up coming
in at number 9 episode 168 was myself
and John Faust hey John meeting with Ian
and Carrie talking about Nvidia and
their t4 chip this was lots of fun as
well we got to actually go down to the
Nvidia headquarters which honestly if
you haven't seen photos of the Nvidia
headquarters is the most unbranded seen
in my life
all the Nvidia branding looks like
they're building it's all black
triangles it's a gorgeous it's also a
lovely building but yeah we got to have
a really great conversation about like
accelerated computing and machine
learning and all the stuff that the new
t4 chip allows them to do lots and lots
of good fun stuff around that of course
you get the t4 chip now in GCP which was
the whole point and so you can do neat
stuff most of it was just like above my
head but it all sounded fantastic like
yes well I think everyone definitely
wants more GPUs for whatever process or
whatever workloads are using that arm or
GPU focused but I'm kind of jealous of
actually going to the campus and seeing
what that looks like and John was super
happy because you know the RT X series
had just come out for the Nvidia chip so
he was like oh my god I'm in video and
so this also sounds like a lot
fun well on episode at number eight we
have human-centered AI with Die dang so
die is a Google developer advocate as
well but she's focusing more on the AI
side actually I think she's a design
advocate yes
design advocate at Google that was you
and I mark and we got to sit down with
died she's a design advocate here at
Google and talk about the human centered
AI guidebook that they were creating
which is really a set of kind of best
practices and things to think about when
creating an AI system especially a
dialogue system to talk with people and
what kind of best practices you should
keep in mind for that I thought it was
really interesting to hear about the
kind of things one that really stuck
with me was this idea of personification
and turning like you know non people
type objects into people and how that
really impacts especially younger Minds
when they're interacting with AI I think
it was really fascinating tips in there
and so you know AI is not nearly my area
of expertise but it was really cool to
kind of see someone taking a stance and
saying you know here's some research
that backs up these best practices and
here's what we recommend you do as
opposed to what you know kind of is
happening now is just explosion of all
these different AI systems being built
possibly without guidelines so they
could be all over the place super
interesting episode as well
they released something didn't they yeah
they had the actual guidebook was
released shortly after that episode so
definitely recommend people check that
out and the show notes down there but it
was you know it's kind of fascinating to
see what that actually looked like and
what they were recommending people do
okay
number 774 is professional services
which I got to do with Emily which it's
awesome this is just a basically list of
my favorite people so we got to meet
with Anne Wallace and Michael woman
talking about professional services
organization or PS oh basically they
were the post sales department this is
just really cool to see like how the PSO
team works with customers so you helped
them build some of the things that they
need to get built basically so like they
go through some customer examples and
they went through some things that
they've worked on and and how they'd
helped certain people and we touched on
a whole bunch of stuff from SRA CRE to
consulting services to all the products
basically which is very reflective of
how kind of the PSO org works you know
or Google you know when they're working
with customers it'll be anything from
implementation to support to training
across the entire breadth of Google
cloud products so it makes sense that
there be a wide variety covered there
six on the list we have episode 164
which was no js' with Miles mark that
was you and John talking about it but I
know from talking with Miles
he is always excited to lay down some
serious knowledge on nodejs
absolutely did I mention this is
basically just a list of my favorite
people
again miles yeah it's all the nodejs
things what was cool I actually liked
about this as well as we kind of just
went through like all the different ways
no GS touches Google Cloud and it's a
long list I mean we cover doses of the
stuff that was kind of internal to
like--how'd nodejs works and like some
of the fun things about the governance
and like all that kind of stuff but it
was actually just really cool to be like
okay like where are all the things that
no Jess goes through from like App
Engine to Apps Script to bigquery to
like all this kind of stuff so if you're
no js' developer check out this episode
yeah and definitely if you're interested
in node follow miles yeah mouse is great
he talks a lot about node and he's a
really great guy so definitely recommend
checking him out so number five halfway
there oh look it's you and me again
meeting with Jen person again favorite
peasants so Jen's great Jen gave us a
update on what's been happening with
firebase client five story just come out
of beta at the time and cloud functions
for firebase is also out at that point
and so Jen gave us a whole walkthrough
of all kinds of cool stuff that's going
on with firebase all kinds of cool
information there well just oh the cool
stuff yeah Jen's fantastic you should
follow Jen Jen's now working I believe
on Google cloud so you can follow her
for Google cloud stuff yeah definitely
excited to see all the new stuff Jen's
working on but yeah she was also very
heavily ingrained with firebase for the
past two years or so so at this
conversation earlier this year just
everything firebase so definitely
recommend checking it out if you all are
big firebase fans next up number four
getting close we've got Kay native mark
that was you and Gabby talking to some
great people about what Kay native is
and of course the first question that
comes out of this is what is Kay native
what is Kay native it's probably a
delicious low-fat breakfast cereal it is
a I like to call it like an open source
platform as-a-service
so it's an opinionated tool chain for
building applications on top of
kubernetes and deploying in order
scaling and all that kind of you know
fun stuff but yeah it was interesting
around that
you know can ativ had really sort of hit
the scene so to speak everyone was
pretty excited about it
so we got a really good opportunity to
go through like what kind of it is what
it does how it works how you can get
started with it listen in on some of the
history behind it as well so yeah you
know it's one of the hot things going on
in native and as a spoiler it's not the
last time we'll hear about service on
kubernetes in this list probably not but
before we talk about that
we'll go to episode 3 which was episode
175 talking about [ __ ] database that
was you and John talking about all the
things that were [ __ ] yeah this was
great we had a great chat with Andrew
Davidson from MongoDB talking about
first of all like what is MongoDB you
know sequel databases as a whole and
like how they work it was also really
interesting to hear about their
commercial product MongoDB Atlas which
you can run on top of Google Cloud so if
you're looking for a managed platform
for MongoDB that could be a great
opportunity for you as well so coming in
at number 2 we have Python with Dustin
Ingram speaking of favorite people also
joined by Brian Dorsey Brian and Dustin
are fantastic just do a recap of what's
going on with Python on Google cloud
very much like we talked with miles
about node talking about all the really
interesting cool stuff that's going on
with Python and all the places it can
touch and Google cloud including things
like cloud functions and how we support
things like flask they're at one of
their frameworks and like all kinds of
other fun things app engine Yeti Yeti at
all the cool things yeah I talked to
Dustin after this episode came out and
he was really surprised with just how
many people are interested in hearing
more about Python well first of all of
course there's a couple of Python
developers out there like just a few
just a couple here oh yeah right
I hear it's an up-and-coming language
yeah I heard that you know he was really
excited to see what the response was and
obviously Dustin works a lot on Python
but the reality is you know very similar
to some of the other episodes we've been
seeing here it's really about how these
things work across the entire cloud
ecosystem and what you can do with them
if you know Python great bring that to
cloud you don't really need to like
learn a new language or do anything like
that much easier yep absolutely
all right last one that leaves us with
the first and top episode of this year
we're not editing a drumroll here we're
gonna put the episode on pause until
mark does a actual drumroll
there it is and our number 1 episode was
cloud run hinting at it a few times
throughout here but it was actually an
episode that we recorded it next and
those episodes were fantastic all
admittedly just kind of a
caffeine-fueled couple of days where we
tried to stay awake for all the events
and activities but we also got a great
chance to sit down with a huge number of
people as they came by the Google cloud
podcast booth and talked about a wide
variety of things well in this episode I
think the real key cornerstone of this
was us talking to starin and Ryan about
cloud run so they're both you know
product managers here at Google and they
were kind of announcing because this had
also come out clap next was the beta for
cloud run and basically this idea of
being able to server lessly serve a
container and it's backed by kubernetes
and really Kay native it's this managed
container serving offering and everyone
was super excited about it and I think
that was kind of just like the the
greatest kind of conversation to
understand what is this you know we
haven't seen this before we've seen some
similar things why is it exciting and it
sounds like people really were
interested in hearing more about it yeah
it sounds like this is a really cool
thing not entirely shocked that this is
number one at all no I mean it's such a
huge you know conversation topic right
now and especially as you know as more
and more people get used to the
ecosystem and what that looks like I
think we'll be hearing a lot more cool
use cases and seeing like oh look at
this kind of possible architecture that
was just not doable yeah until cloud run
came around yeah clowns beanie I should
sit down and play with it it seems like
something I should do it's super fun
definitely highly recommend it and
actually it turns out it's super easy in
fact I know a podcast episode you should
probably listen to about it I listened
to all the episodes mostly some of the
time this this one was because it was a
next episode we did get a lot of
different people in there and it was
great to definitely talk about that and
highly recommend checking that out as
well as the other 10 episodes we
mentioned but also the 200 before those
just because it turns out we talk about
a lot of great things before we finish
up for the year mark what's been your
favorite things this year what stuff
have you been particular excited about
announcement wise or well you know like
I said we've talked about so many
different things I think cloud run is
probably the coolest thing that we've
talked about because it's just such an
effortless and cool way to look at
hosting containers I know you're a huge
kubernetes fan a little bit and you know
maybe you bring it up over
once or twice an episode but sometimes
you just want to host your container and
you don't want to deal with the rest
some sent and and that's where a cloud
run when I heard about it I was super
excited I've had a chance to play around
with it a bit and I'm really looking
forward to kind of just doing everything
that way now because I don't wanna I
don't wanna I don't wanna Amal I just
want to just make it work just do it
right do it so that is by far this year
been the coolest thing I've had a chance
to see and talk about sweet we haven't
mentioned this in the podcast actually
but I just say like it's a Google thing
that has just got me very excited the
stadia launch games
I mean steady is magic and it's so good
because of this I can't put down Samurai
Shodown it's one of the free pro games
because I've signed up and I keep
playing it and it's wonderful first of
all I just think it's super cool second
about just massive congratulations to
that team for just pulling off something
that is just technologically uschoene
we're breaking as far as I'm concerned
pure magic yeah I mean you want to talk
about things that may not have been
possible before this kind of
introduction like I mean this ability to
stream all the cloud resources your
computer it like I know that I didn't
need yet another surface to play destiny
on and yet Here I am here you are yeah
yeah now I just need to be able to play
destiny on three surfaces at once there
you go there you go
so it's fine if you can play on your
switch can you play switch no but I
really wish I could there you go if you
could play switch plus your console plus
your PC plus stadium it just drain all
the internet from my house and all the
life from my activities yeah you don't
need to go outside
but yeah so stadia what am i cute for
everything's the year I just also want
to say other favorite thing in the air
it's really the delightful to hear all
the new voices on the podcast as well
and here oh the new hosts and what a
great job you're all doing it was it was
bittersweet to sit down but super happy
to hear everything that's going on with
the podcast with all of you all so yeah
let's jump everyone well I can
definitely say thank you because I'm
right here and I'm sure many of our
other hosts share the sentiment because
it's just been so exciting to get this
broad range of people talking about all
these different things it's just super
cool and it adds a lot of cool
perspectives to all the conversations we
have so hopefully all the listeners are
also enjoying the mix up of different
topics and different hosts absolutely
cool all right so where are you gonna be
before you finish up for the year well
we are coming to the end of the year
which means it's a little bit of a
holiday season if you're into holidays
if not then it's just kind of December
and January
either way I'm going to sleep I'm gonna
take a nice bear hibernation nice maybe
stay in my room for about three months
probably playing stadium how about
yourself
yeah I would like to take a break
unfortunately everything is already
ramped up for next year so oh no all the
planning for game developers conference
all the planning for Google cloud next
all the planning for i/o that's just
kicking on kicking on so because this
train never stops just finding a way to
make it to the next stop yeah but
probably doing a lot of lying down in
bed with my dog it'll be fine that's the
exciting part awesome well it's been a
fantastic year and always super excited
to chat with mark I'm sure you'll
probably see him and one or two other
future episodes as cool things come up
or we get more a gonna slated content
maybe we'll see the promises we'll see
we'll see well to all the listeners
slash viewers just doesn't matter how
you're listening to this very very
excited to have you all with us through
this year and hopefully we will see you
early next year as well hang on a second
fellas Gabby and John have recorded a
special bonus segment for the holidays
so without further delay here we go I am
Gabby and I'm here with my colleague
John hello John how are you I'm doing
pretty well had a lot of fun at the
holiday party that was fun everybody was
so fancy yeah it was you looked really
nice yesterday yeah I was like I'm gonna
dress up you know this for one occasion
at the year so John today is the last
episode of the year right yep definitely
isn't it's been a very very interesting
year full of very very interesting
guests and really new and interesting
product updates so it was definitely a
lot of fun getting to talk about all
those things on the podcast oh yeah
definitely
a lot of new hosts yes - I don't
remember everybody's name right now
because there is people that onion
didn't had the pleasure to record
everything yet but I'm happy that we
have all these people collaborating with
us so John let's talk about favorite
episodes one of my favorite episodes we
did together was the data visualization
with Manuel Lima and that was really fun
because we got to talk pretty much the
creator of a brand new team built
specifically and seeing metrics around
like Google products and
turn le and making things work it was
just awesome because he was just full of
energy you weren't in the room with him
but he was just like glowing with
excitement we just talking about data
visualization it was just amazing yeah
that's one of my favorites for the
reason that it's a inter-department
effort that he does not just he's on the
part with Michael our products he helps
with like visualization for the query
and also he works together with team of
material design so I learned a lot of
him like we wanted to do like a new I'll
tell you what my second favorite one was
a recording with Mark Mendel and was the
PI world record with Emma yeah that's
right Eve oh yeah
he was really fun she was very excited
about all the work and she explained how
she figured out machine configurations
to make it work for calculating that
amount of digits of pi when I talked to
Emma about how she went about creating
it she told me that she had already been
running it for several days and I was
like mom this actually right I think she
ran in for a couple of months and then
when I heard that I was like our GCP
bills gonna be really expensive for Emma
really put her heart and soul into that
project and I'm glad that she not only
want you know Guinness world record but
it was just like amazing to know that we
actually know like the person on a team
that really like put forth this effort
and you don't really accomplish
something really amazing and she's very
accessible like she has her feet on the
ground she's one of my favorite persons
and she likes my happy - well I don't
know about feet underground because
she's always traveling so if you ever
happened to bump into Emma in any
country just know that she's pretty much
just loves being everywhere else so
another one of my favorite episodes is
the Phoenix labs episode that we did
with Jesse Houston mark and I sat down
and we got to talk to the CEO of Phoenix
labs and it was amazing because we got
to talk to them about the process
working with Google and getting ready
for launch of dauntless and if you
haven't played dauntless it's really fun
I played it several times before our
podcast and I played it for like I think
a month or two after before other new
games came out and I just started adding
more games to my backlog so it was
really interesting to hear how they had
engineers come into their war room right
before lunch and they were just
crunching through everything and
debugging and you know pretty much just
going over metrics and quotas and you
know making sure that everything's
perfect for lunch and it is really
interesting to see like that full cycle
of working with our internal teams to
make sure that their launch was
successful the concept of working that
much together to launch something cool
it's priceless because you learn new
things and also there's the adrenaline
jump you know like oh my god I need to
do this and then when you want you're
like so oppressive is this gonna fail
this is gonna work so my other favorite
episode that's one that we did together
John it's with Zak Akhil where he talks
about email things and he's awesome
demos right I'm a big fan of zak and him
being like a maker and just taking all
of his personal interests and you can
see like it reflects in the demos that
he does but they're so informative and
they're really complex projects that
spanned several products of GCP so it's
really cool to see him really taking his
interest in running with it and building
really cool things it's one of your
favorite story yeah for sure
and Zak is probably one of my favorite
people as well
solely because he and I share not only a
lot of these same interest but we are
both makers as well and we both try to
incorporate like our personal interest
in all of our projects so I can see Zak
and I being really good friends for a
really long time that's cool definitely
happy nice between your life makes
things better exactly he was a bit shy
in the beginning but like he came
through in the end like really nice
personality yeah
my other favorite episode as well semi
semi technologies were floor yeah I
remember that one we did it together
favorite yeah she talked about knowledge
graph which
no like much about it I can't explain it
go to episode 198 if you want to listen
to it and she has the same profession as
us developer relations so she talks a
bit about how she does use her work for
the company and we v8 which it is their
open-source tool for the knowledge graph
that they work on and it was nice seeing
someone also passionate about what they
do and helping build a product that they
are talking about I really enjoyed that
episode because I got to talk about the
meaning of things as it pertains to
knowledge graphs in how the meaning of
one word can mean something in one
universe versus another universe and if
you listen to the episode you get to
listen to me really rent and go on and
on and on about this because I compare
how medicine may be one way in like
Harry Potter's universe versus our
universe you know so definitely a lot of
fun and and Laura was just really great
yeah she was awesome and my final
favorite episode was with face it with
Marie story that episode was really fun
because it's not every day that I get to
talk to women who work in gaming and it
was really interesting to know that
someone has taken a time to really make
gaming a friendly place where they're
trying to fight toxicity within games so
I got to sit down with Brian and we got
to really pick her brain about what
makes things very toxic in games what is
the common trends that you see in
toxicity in games and we had to see the
technology that that face it has built
running on GCP to actually fight this so
it's something that I openly admitted
that I participated in on the podcast
mm-hmm it's it's just great to know that
you know there's a platform to actually
make gaming a better place yeah
definitely we need more of that we see
things that happen and like having
someone that worries about that it's
definitely important it's actually kind
of funny because I have friends who tell
me that they would never play online
competitive multiplayer games strictly
because of how toxic it is so hopefully
we can change their minds and
there's also places on the internet that
I don't go because like I just don't go
there
so that's up for or favorite episodes
what did you do this year that you liked
one of my favorite things was when I
first joined Google I got to see mark
and Melanie doing the podcast in the
middle of next in 2018 and this year I
got to be a part of that so we were like
smack dab in the middle of next and we
got to do the podcast and we had a whole
bunch of people come through and do like
small episodes some of them didn't make
a cut but it was just really great to
you know talk to all these people doing
see what the interesting things they
were building up yeah that was a lot of
fun I remember that day unfortunately
not all episode because we courted like
the whole Bay of stuff and like so many
things didn't make it but definitely
gave us ideas of to bring more people in
we actually brought some of those guests
back as full episodes as well so yeah
cauldron I think was one of them
another cool thing was for an episode I
got to go to Nvidia's office and that
was extremely fun mark and I went
together and he always says nvidia has
one of the best branded offices as far
as color schemes because like everything
is like like glass and green highlights
everywhere and their office is extremely
nice and I won't say whose food is
better but I will say that they had a
very good selection depends on the
office you go at Google depends a lot
you know and then you get amazing food
and good food you know and the other
thing was I got to talk to a lot of
guests that are in a gaming industry
mostly women which is really great and I
got to hear how passionate they are and
see about the cool things are building
on GCP and it just you know hearing all
of these experts in this field really
inspires me to you know continue to a
lot of the world I try to do is really
interesting and that's one of my
favorite things from the podcast as well
favorite thing where all started which
it is joining the podcast and that has
been an adventure you know getting to
who research and learn because we want
to make right by our audience and like
there's stuff that sometimes were not
experts we can't be experts so
everything but it makes for good
episodes we
we ask questions that we want to learn
from those people that were interviewing
that has been a cool thing to be doing
in this year yeah I will say that I
learned quite a bit it was just amazing
knowing that like I got to learn a lot
from our guests and I got to learn a lot
from the hopes that came before me like
Marc would tell me a bunch of things
audience doesn't know but one of the
funniest things that I think for us with
the podcast when we first joined was you
and I did not have the right equipment
so like in our first episodes I don't
think our audio was that Greek or who
was stunning in yeah like when they got
like oh my god how much I put the game
on the microphone you know the editors
do magic yeah yeah thanks to our editors
so Gabby what about your favorite things
of the year so beyond joining the
podcast I got to visit at a lot of
offices we do have an internal
competition on that but like nothing
like the people that has been there for
a while but definitely I got to see like
London and like in Portugal because like
I was on vacation it was like I'm gonna
go to the office just to see how it
isn't either food like not only to be
badge into every office but tasting the
food and comparing it because everyone
says this office has the best food this
office has the best food and being able
to go do that it's definitely pretty fun
although I'm although I'm not big on
trying everything at cafes I like to
stick what I'm used to so I can actually
make very informed decisions about which
food is better oh yeah yeah I like the
noodles on our office in New York oh
yeah another one that I like people may
find it weird but I did a talk on call
next and my demo fail but what I liked
about it it's like I was able to recover
from it and deliver the talk because one
of the points that was making John it's
like how unreliable it is to do local
development sometimes and he actually
failed locally but he worked on the
cloud so that's really cool yeah I was
like it works on the cloud that's what I
want that's show you know it's funny I
find that our audience is during our
talks because I've also had a demo fail
this year they learned quite a bit from
see
our demos Vil see that there were real
things and then being able to recover
and still you know pass along that
information and even have some success
coming out of the filled demos it's
really good for our audiences I can
definitely relate to you in that one
yeah it's funny because like I don't
panic
like Oh high stress situations actually
my money enters in gears you know and
like I'm able to do stuff that I
wouldn't be doing if like I was normal
situation you know and that was nice
because like perturb the NA debug your
demo if is nobody failed just don't go
deep there because it's up rabbit hole
you know and I'm glad that I didn't know
that that was a good good decision and
while I was doing that one of my
favorite things was also spreading the
love on databases I know a lot of people
think like that abases are boring but
like I find it awesome I find it awesome
being able to put things on their own
place you know and database
normalization how you organize your data
and learning different types because
it's not a competition there's things
like if you use Redis for gaming because
you you need fast caching you need
session saving putting that on a
relational database for instance it's
not ideal that it's like what I like
bringing to the people the awareness of
all the options that you have there but
now for you to replace it but for you to
have an informed decision of what you
put on your stack so that's one of the
things I like doing
you're just as passionate about
databases I am with gaming which makes
us good on our jobs yeah not perfect
another favorite thing of the year just
really really small will probably be on
the podcasts it'll probably be the
numerous amount of outtakes that we do
and there are hilarious I wish we could
like just do an episode just about sage
I love how the humming became a thing on
one of the episodes yeah when I passed
it along to my friends and they were
like okay that's something you would
totally do so where are you gonna be
well it's in 30 years
to be home hopefully playing some games
but mostly planning gaming content for
next year and just wrapping up this year
with a lot of deep dive into multiplayer
games how they're built and you know a
lot of trade offs and you know trying to
optimize and really make the gaming
products that we are trying to build up
very good for our developer communities
depending on how deep I dive into the
multiplayer game stuff I may actually
push out some content right before the
end of the year if you're following look
out for it how about you Gabby so winter
is coming and I can't stand in there
March some also having vacation where
I'll be running away to a warm weather
so no winter for me I mean not much you
know I'm still gonna be here in January
February but like on the end of the year
I just want to be on the beach which is
nice another favorite thing in the
podcast I love how Gabby
just sets up all of our sound clips I
think she purposely puts winter is
coming for a sound bit from Game of
Thrones because it sure is coming you
know that's gonna do it for Gabby and I
for this episode so thank you all for
listening and definitely look forward to
seeing you all next year yeah I'll talk
to you next year from all of us at the
podcast we'd like to wish you and Merry
Christmas a Happy Hanukkah a wonderful
PS to a variety of Guadeloupe an
excellent Kwanzaa a spiritual and
moussaka and a magical Saturnalia and if
you're just into science we hope that
all your hypotheses come through
[Music]